five billion years from now the Sun will
expand and become a red giant and the
earth might just be in the way if humans
were still around then would we leave
the earth or would we move it this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we moved the earth
what's the sun's problem anyway well
like any other star it has an expiration
date the beginning of its end will
feature our Sun swelling into a red
giant wiping out everything that happens
to be orbiting it too closely like the
earth if we wanted to survive we'd need
to take action long before the Sun
started going on a rampage it would take
a billion space shuttles to evacuate
about seven and a half billion
Earthlings
even if we could launch 1,000 space
shuttles every day it would take over
2700 years to move everyone off the
doomed planet maybe we could save
ourselves some trouble by moving our
whole planet instead that's actually
quite possible we'd only need to give
the earth one big boost in the right
direction and keep it on course and
there are a few ways to do that to move
the planet out of danger we'd have to
change its velocity by 1,200 meters per
second that would require about 7,000 of
the most powerful rockets ever built but
this plan has one big flaw to escape the
sun's expanding flames we'd need to
escape pretty far at least move into the
orbit of Mars moving something as bulky
as the earth to a safe zone there might
take us billions of years and for every
billion years that passed we'd use up
about a third of the Earth's mass as
propellant that's not very efficient is
it to move the earth more efficiently
we'd have to consider electric
propulsion
[Music]
unlike the chemical one used in most
Rockets electric propulsion doesn't
require a lot of mass we could get away
with sacrificing only 2% of the Earth's
mass every billion years you'd hardly
notice the difference
but this option would require a lot of
power about eight hundred times more
than what's produced here on earth right
now plus it would take some careful
engineering to make this work
because the earth is spinning a rocket
placed in one location would not always
point in the right direction
we'd need to place Rockets all around
the earth and have each of them fire
only for a certain amount of time that
would keep the earth on course it would
take a billion years to move the planet
out of the danger zone any
miscalculation could mean extinction
there is a better way and it involves
asteroids aerospace engineers use
something called a gravitational
slingshot to alter a spacecraft's path
without using too much propellant when a
spacecraft approaches the earth and then
leaves its gravitational pull it
receives some of the Earth's orbital
energy we could use the same effect to
redirect our planet first we'd have to
make comets or asteroids pass close to
the earth transferring some of their
energy in the process
next engineers would redirect the
asteroids close to Jupiter and Saturn
where they would pick up some of the gas
giants energy from there the asteroids
would bring that energy back to earth
we'd repeat the process over and over
again until it got us to a safe orbit of
course that would be quite dangerous too
the slightest misconduct
into the planet and destroy our life as
we know it now we wouldn't be taking the
moon on our road trip around the solar
system most likely we ditch our
celestial partner the moment we pushed
Earth's orbit away from the Sun now the
big risk here is that moving the earth
might disrupt the whole planetary system
it could easily destabilize mercury or
Venus setting them on the path of
destruction and there's no one living on
those planets that can save them at
least not that we know about maybe we'd
be better off terraforming another
planet to use as our new home but that's
a story for another what if
you